อามารุได้ไง
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะดีค่ะ
ต้องก็
ในเนื้อหา
ค่ะกับครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูฟ้านะคะให้แล้ววัน
นี้ฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันอังคาร
วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้วันอังคารหรอวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
25 เดี๋ยวที่ 25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคม
ค่ะ
ปีพตอะไรคะมีผช 2565
เมื่อปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะแล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศต.ค.ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
26 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศต.ค.ปีพต 2  1565  a  Call สปีคศ 2
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 นค่ะ 11:00 นที่นาทีคะ
6 นาทีค่ะ
11:06 นะก็เป็นเวลากลางวันมันเป็นเวลา
กลางวันครูฟ้าเนี่ย 11:06 ผู้หญิงกี่โมง
นะครูหญิงนะคะถ้าถ้า 7:00
ผมลาทีค่ะ
11:06 น
ของผู้หญิงเนี่ยกลางคืน
กลางคืนครูฟ้าเนี่ยกลางวันวันชัยรักใจดี
เออแล้ว
ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ที่บ้านไหมคะ
ตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านค่ะครูหญิงไฟฟ้าอยู่
บ้านผู้หญิงอยู่บ้านไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่ได้
อยู่บ้านค่ะผู้หญิงอยู่ที่ไหนคะกูหญิง
เนี่ย
อยู่เป็น
อพาร์ทเม้นท์
ทานเม้นที่หน้า 1  2
3  4
5  6 คิดว่ามี 6 ชั้นแล้วครูหญิงอยู่
ชั้นที่เท่าไหร่อันนี้ชั้น 1 ใช่ไหมคะ
ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ชั้น 4 ชั้น 5 ชั้น 6 ครู
หญิงอยู่ชั้นสองค่ะเห็นไหมรออยู่ชั้น 2
อันที่ 2 นะคะต้อง
จ่ายอาผู้หญิง
ไม่คุยจะถามว่าแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกูฟ้าไม่ได้
อยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์เนาะอยู่บ้านนะบ้านครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยมีชั้นไหมคะ
บ้านกูผ้ามีฉันหาผู้หญิงเหชั้นคะครูฟ้ามี
2 ชั้นอ๋อ
122 ชั้นตอนนี้เนี่ยตอนเนี้ยนี่ครูฟ้า
อยู่ครูฟ้าอยู่ชั้น 1 หรือว่าว่าชั้น 2
ลูกฟ้าอยู่ชั้นที่ 2 ค่ะฉันที่สนเหมือน
ผู้หญิงเลย
ผู้หญิงก็อยู่ชั้นที่ 2 ครูฟ้าก็ชั้นที่ 2
ช
ก็เหมือนกันแต่ไม่เหมือนกันก็คือครูฟ้า
อยู่บ้านหรอกคุยอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์ใช่ไหมคะ
เดี๋ยวจะมาดูบ้านของครูฟ้ากัน
ได้หาบ้านใช่ไหมอันนี้บ้านครูฟ้า
บ้านครูฟ้ามี 2 ชั้นชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 แล้วก็
ถ้าที่บ้านก็จะมีหลังคาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะมีหลังคา
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยหลังคาสีอะไรอ่ะ
ที่บ้านครูบาตาสีน้ำเงิน
หลังคาสีน้ำเงินนี่เฮ้ยสีน้ำเงิน
หลังคาสีน้ำเงินแล้วบ้านครูฟ้าล่ะตรงนี้
มีสีอะไร
สีขาวค่ะสีขาวได้ไหมคะเหงา
อีกหลังคาสีน้ำเงินเราก็มี 2 ชั้นน้อง
แล้วที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีประตูไหมคะเนี่ยประตู
มีประตูค่ะมีนะมีประตูเนื้องอไม่มีประตู
ไม่ได้ไม่มีอยู่ตัวก็มีหน้าสาดเอ้าที่
บ้านครูฟ้ามีประตูแล้วก็มีหน้าต่าง
สะวันนาตะ
หน้าต่างหน้าต่าง
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยรู้ไหมคะว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้า
เนี่ยครูฟ้ามีประตู
เท่าไรอ่ะมีประตู
แอบดู
ผู้พันนับก่อนมี 1 ประตูหน้าบ้าน
ประตูหน้าบ้านเนาะตู้หน้าบ้านนะฮะแล้วก็
ประตูหลังบ้าน
ข้างหลังสมัยข้างหลังบ้านข้างหลังนาประตู
หลังบ้านแล้วก็ 1  2 ประตูห้องนอน 3  4  5
6  7  8
ประตูห้องน้ำเก้า
ห้องครัว 10
R2 พระ 11
กุมภากล่องรับนะ
11-6 งอก
น่าจะมี 11
ครับครูครูบามีประตูทั้งหมด 11 ประตูผี
ดีแล้วครูฟ้าบอกว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
หน้าต่างสมัยมีหน้าต่างชั้นหนึ่งเนาะชั้น
1 นะคะชั้น 1 มีหน้าต่างไหมคะฉันที่ 1
มีหน้าต่างค่ะคือผู้หญิงแล้วชั้น 1 บ้าน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีหน้าต่างกี่บาน
คือ 1  2  3
3  4
7  7 บาทแล้วฉันหนึ่งมี 7 บาทแล้วชั้น
สองแล้วคะชั้น 2B หน้าต่างกี่บานฉันที่ 2
มี 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9
20 หมู่
10 บาทมีหน้าต่างสิบบาทหู
11  11
51 ไม่ใช้สิหรอ
11 บาทหรอชั้น 2 มี 11 บานชั้น 1 มี 7
บานใช่ไหมคะแล้วบ้านครูฟ้ามี 2 ชั้นเนี่ย
ชั้น 1 ไปชั้น 2 บ้านครูฟ้าก็ต้องมีบันได
ใช่ไหมคะมีบันได
บันไดตลกฟ้าเนี่ยต๊อกแต๊กต๊อกแต๊กตกๆๆๆ
แล้วก็ขึ้นฉัน 2 มีบันไดมีมันได้มีเพื่อน
ได้กี่หัน
ไม่รู้
ไม่มีบันไดเนี่ย 1  2  3  4  5
เท่าไหร่อะนี้ครูฟ้ากูไม่รู้กูป่าวว่าน่า
จะประมาณ 13  14 ขั้นนะ
Hurt จำได้นิดหน่อยนะ 1  2  3  V5 เออ
อ่ะที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยหามี 2 ชั้นใช่ไหม
มีหลังคามีประตูมี
หน้าต่างมีบันไดแล้วที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
อะนี้ไหมคะ
อะไรอ่ะผู้หญิง
มี
เห็นไหมเนี่ยมีระเบียงไหมแบบนี้เราเรียก
ว่าเราเตียง
มีค่ะ
ที่บ้านพราวฟ้ามีอะไรเบียงชั้น 1 หรือ
ชั้น 2 คะ
ฉัน 2 ค่ะ
ชั้น 1 มีระเบียงไหม
สมัครเวลารหมอเขาก็จะยื่นออกมาแบบนี้เนาะ
ผู้หญิงก็ว่าไม่ค่อยเป็นนะคะนักเรียน
Abstract เอาแล้วกันนะคะประมาณนี้เนาะมี
ระเบียงที่ชั้น 2 ในหาฉันที่ 2
[เพลง]
แล้ว
อันที่ 1 ไม่มีระเบียงชั้นที่ 1 น่าจะไม่
มีใช่ไหมคือนักเรียนชั้นที่ 2 ใช่รัก
แค่นี้ทำไมบ้านทรายบ้านบ้านครูหญิงล่ะผู้
หญิงอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์น่ะจ่ายกูยิ่งอยู่
อพาร์ทเม้นท์แต่บางครั้งคนไทยก็บอกว่า
บ้านใช่มั้ยบ้านนาว่าถ้าครูหญิงครูฟ้า
เนี่ยไปกินข้าวเสร็จคุยเหมาะบ๊ายบายครู
ฟ้าเก่าแน่นอนหลับบ้านแต่ผู้หญิงไม่ได้
อยู่บ้านแต่พูดบ้านนะคะม 3 บ้านผู้หญิง
Apartment ผู้หญิงมีประตูไหมคะ
มีนะนี่วีซี่ใช่ไหมครูฟ้ามาถามครูหญิง
เนี่ยอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์ที่ชั้น 2 ใช่ไหมคะ
ชั้น 2 เนี่ยมีประตูค่ะครูฟ้ามีประตู
มีประตูกี่บานคะนี่ประตู 1
3  3 ค่ะมีประตู 3 บาน
น้อยเนาะครูฟ้ามีประตู 11 บานครูหญิงมี 3
บาน
ได้สาบานแล้ว
ครูหญิงมีหน้าต่างไหมคะอากาศอ่างใช่ไหม
อ่าหน้าต่างนะคะมีค่ะครูฟ้ากริ่งก็มีหน้า
ตาอย่าง
ถ้าผู้หญิงมีหน้าต่างกี่บาทนะ
1  2 มีหน้าต่าง 2 บานค่ะฮินาตะ 2 บาท
พระ Apartment เนาะใช่เหมือนบ้านก็มี
หน้าต่าง 2 บาน
แล้วกูหญิงมีระเบียงไหมคะ
ระเบียงแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
ที่ให้ดูเนาะคิดว่านั่งเล่นดูไปแล้วใช่
ไหมคะ
ก็ระเบียงสมัครระเบียงที่ยื่นออกมานอน
หรือว่าถ้าซูมก็จะเป็นแบบประมาณนี้นะคะ
ระเบียงนี่ระเบียงค่ะครูป๊าป๊าน้องที่
บ้านครูหญิงมีระเบียง
111 จ้า
แล้วผู้หญิง
ประตู 3 วันก็ต้องมี 3 ห้องใช่ไหมมีกี่
ชายชาย We  Are เราก็ Apartment เนี่ยนะ
คะครูฟ้าก็มีอะไรเหมือนกัน
มีบันได
ผู้หญิงก็เดินขึ้นบันไดใช่ไหมเดินขึ้น
บันไดโอเคแล้วก็มีลิฟต์ด้วยค่ะมีมีๆไม่มี
ฤทธิ์
สายมีลิฟต์น้องทั้งนักเรียนกฎแล้วก็
การ์ตูนลิฟต์เปิดแล้วก็เดินเข้าไปแล้วรอ
ลิฟต์ก็มี
ผู้หญิงชอบขึ้นลิฟต์หรือขึ้นบันไดคะ
ผู้หญิงชอบขึ้นลิฟท์ค่ะไม่เหนื่อย
แล้วให้พี่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีบันไดใช่ไหม
มีฤทธิ์ไหมคะที่ว่าโห
ก็มีลิฟต์เหรอไม่มีลิฟต์ละไม่มีเลย
บ้างค้ามี 2 ชั้น
ฉันแล้วหน้าตาไม่ชอบลิปนะฮะ
ภูฟ้าเนี่ยพวกฟ้าชอบบันไดใช่ไหมมันไม่ชอบ
เเรพ
i5 ตัวลิฟท์
แล้วในบ้านครูฟ้าสมัยช่างในเนาะครั้งใน
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทย
เนาะเราเป็นคนไทยประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันร้อน
ใช่ไหมร้อนอาจจะแบบ
35 องศาเซลเซียส
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีแอร์ไหมคะแต่ฉันที่
มีลมทักมาแล้วก็เปิด 25  25 องศาเนี่ย
แอร์
ช่างแอร์เย็นๆเวลาร้อนก็เปิด
เอ้อใช่ไหมเปิดแอร์แอร์ 25 องศา
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีแอร์ไหมคะที่บ้านครู
ขามีแอร์แอร์ค่ะมีกี่เครื่องทางบ้านเนาะ
บ้านทั้งหลังสมัยครั้งหลังมีแอร์กี่
เครื่อง
บ้านทั้งหลังมีแอร์แอร์ 5 เครื่องค่ะ
ค่าเครื่องห้าเครื่องใช่ฮะว่าประเทศไทย
มันร้อนใช่ไหมแต่ครูบาก็เปิดแอร์นิดหน่อย
นะขายเปิดไม่เปิดแอร์สายแต่มีแอร์แอร์ค่า
เครื่องใช่ไหมหาเครื่องแล้วครูหญิงมีแอร์
ไหมคะ
ที่
กรุงเทพฯที่กรุงเทพเนี่ยมีแอร์ค่ะแล้วที่
อเมริกาอยู่ที่อเมริกาไม่มีแอร์ผัวตอนนี้
เนี่ย
หนาวมากเนาะให้นักเรียนให้ครูฟ้าดูนะคะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบหนาวใช่ไหม
2 องศาเซลเซียส
สงสา
โหยไม่มีแอร์แต่มีคิดติ้จะไปอินเนอร์กิน
เปิดแล้วก็แบบว่าร้อนๆไม่หนาวหรอแล้วปกติ
คืออเมริกาก็ไม่มีแอร์กันใช่ไหมไม่ค่อยมี
น่าจะแต่ว่าฮีตเตอร์ครูหญิงแม่เป็น
ทูอินวันก็คือตอนนี้หนาวใช่ไหมคะก็เปิด
ฮีทเตอร์แต่ถ้าอเมริการ้อนใช่ไหมร้อน
ร้อนก็เกลี่ยนเป็นแอน 4  25 องศาได้แต่
ไม่
น่าจะร้อนนิดหน่อยชายค่ะแต่ตอนโดน
ผู้หญิงก็เลยมีฮิตเตอร์แต่มีฮิตเตอร์
2 เครื่องหรอมีสองนะมียึดเอ้อสองมือ
หนึ่ง
ประเทศไทยไม่มีเธอนะคะไม่มี
โอ้ให้พี่กิตเตอร์
ภามครูฟ้าใช่ไหมครูฟ้าวบอกว่าหลังคาเนาะ
หลังคาบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยสีฟ้าแต่ทำพาสเม้น
เนี่ยไม่มีหลังคาน้องผู้หญิงอยู่
อพาร์ทเม้นท์เนี่ยหลังคาไม่มี
จะเป็นตรงนี้เนี่ยเราไม่เรียกหลังคาเนาะ
หรอบ๊ายบายเรียกว่าเราเรียกว่าเป็นดาดฟ้า
สมัยตรงเนี้ยอ่ะมีฉันข้างบนทำไมเราเรียก
ดาดฟ้าถ้าครูหญิงครูฟ้าอยู่ที่นี่แล้วมี
พระอาทิตย์ก็ร้อนใช่ไหมไม่มีหลังคาแต่
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีหลังคาโพลีหลังคา
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้า
ประตู
ประตูหน้าบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยสีอะไรคะ
ประตูหน้ารู้ไหมสีดำค่ะอ๋อ
สีดำสีดำคู่นี้
แขนสีดำล็อคประตูหน้าบ้านหลังคาสีน้ำเงิน
ประตูหน้าบ้านสีดำ
ผู้หญิงล่ะ
ประตู
4ประตูสีสีเขียว
สีเขียวใหญ่ชายๆเขียวแบบไหนอ่ะเขียวก็มาณ
นี้มั้งนี่ประตูหน้าบ้านครูหญิงอ่ะสี
เขียวค่ะเดี๋ยว
ดีมากผู้หญิง
ไทยไม่มีมั้ยซูซูกิสีเขียวเดี๋ยวผู้หญิง
เห็นแล้วก็ทำไมประตูสีเขียวสีสวยมากผู้
ชายค่ะน้องอันนี้ก็เป็นบ้านของครูหญิง
แล้วก็บ้านของครูฟ้า
บ่ายอ่ะนักเรียนก็ทำนักเรียนบ้านนักเรียน
มีกี่ชั้นมีกิโลทุเรียนบานก็บอกไลน์หรือ
ว่านักเรียนอยู่ชั้นอะไรก็บอกได้น้องใจ
ค่ะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะนะแล้วเจอ
กันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะก็
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ